- Hey guys, I'm Yara, I'm from Grown-ish
and today I will be reading
some college horror stories.
(spooky upbeat music)
So, let's get to it.
- Okay, my question is did
she actually spill milk
or was she imagining it?
I wonder how the rest
of the year went though?
I want to know, if this was
only a couple nights in,
do you just get used to it?
You know, I wouldn't
be mad at that though.
My major plan is that
once I get my degree,
I'm going to create a school
and the only class they'll
teach is called AP Common Sense
and the major skill that
they will be teaching
is how to file taxes.
And you know, I kind of
want to sign this girl up
to teach a class.
It just makes me wonder,
what was she doing
beforehand that inspired her
to go into somebody's
room and file their taxes?
Okay, I don't know how
to respond to that one.
It's almost, how did
they get the goat inside?
How did the goat get into
the dorm in the first place.
It's a lot of creative people in college.
How considerate.
That's amazing, I mean,
the thing is, I've never
stored a rat in our fridge
but I am infamous for having
little experiments that I do
because I used to just use all that really
organic expensive food and like,
I'm going to mix it all together
and I'm going to do some
chemical reaction with it.
There are plenty of times of
having to tell my brothers
that that wasn't food and not to eat it.
So, I can kind of relate.
Squirrels don't like me.
There was a squirrel at my high school
and I had this one long walk.
It would literally just
follow me the entire time
but it was as though
it was waiting for me.
I would see it as soon
as I opened the door,
it would just be sitting there
and I had to try and
get into my class safely
without being attacked by a squirrel.
It was fun times.
(upbeat music)
Thanks for watching guys.